هل تشعر انك مشغول للغايه
انه لا يوجد ما يكفي من الوقت في اليوم
والجدول الزمن الخاص بك يكبر باستمرار
حسيت لازم اسالك يشعر معظم الناس معظم
الناس اليوم بهذه الطريقه ويتحسرون
باستمرار على ضيق الوقت وعدم ايجاد الوقت
الكافي للقيام بمهن بسيطه مثل طهي وجبه او
الخروج في نزهه امر غير صحيحه دراسه نشرت
في موقع لايف هاك تكشف الاسباب التي
تجعلنا نشعر بضيق الوقت
ونقدر في المقابل بعض الحلول المحتمله
التي يمكن ان تساعد على انهاء مهامك في
يوم واحد اهمها وعدم الاستيقاظ مبكرا
وايضا عدم الحصول على قصه كانت من النوم
المزيد معك لميس
هناك عدد اسباب تشعرنا نشعر بضيق الوقت
اهمها عدم الاستيقاظ مبكرا فاذا لم تستيقظ
في وقت المبكر من اليوم فقد تشتكي من عدم
وجود وقت كافر لانجاز كل ما تريد القيام
به ايضا عدم الحصول على قسط كافي من النوم
ليلا فالحصول على النوم يجعلك اكثر
انتاجيه في الصباح
تعدد المهام ايضا يجعلك اقل انتاجيه ويضيع
وقتك في التبديل بين المهام بدل من انجاز
مهمه واحده كما ان الاشخاص الذين يهتمون
كثيرا بالعمل بسرعه ويتصرفون بتهور ينتهي
بهم الامر الى عدم الانتاجيه عدم تتبع
الوقت وعدم التنظيم وعدم ترتيب الاولويات
من الامور الاساسيه التي تجعلك تشعر
بالضيق الوقت التشتت وعدم وجود روتين يومي
في الاشخاص الذين ليس لديهم روتين يتبعونه
كل يوم عرفه الى الان ومن المحتمل ان يفوت
المواعيد النهائيه والمهام التي يجب
القيام بها واذا لم تقوم بمراجعه جداويك
وخططك وعادتك فانت لاضاعه وقتك وطاقتك على
اشياء لم تعد مفيده لقضيتك السلبيه
فالاشخاص الذين يقولون ان ليس لديهم الوقت
للقيام بعمل ما لن يكون لديهم وقت فعليا
للقيام بهذه الاشياء كما ان عدم قدرتك على
قول لا للاخرين قد يؤدي الى القضاء على اي
وقت فراغ كان يمكنك الاسترخافه وينتهي بك
الامر الى الشعور بالارهاق من الاردن
سالنا الناس ما هو اكثر ما يضيع وقتك عليه
[موسيقى]
بريالدو جواك
وبقضي مرت اوقات الكتب والقصص
يعني على الانستغرام سناب شات وعلى
الفيسبوك القراءه
[موسيقى]
والايام العاديه يعني هيك الواحد بيقضي
وقته اغراض بيته تابع امور اولاده
والمساء والله يعني بصراحه يعني بنروح عند
اصحابنا يعني المدرسه
[موسيقى]
القاهره تنضم الينا مدربه الحياه فاتن
سلام مع فاتن سعد صباحك اهلا بك لماذا
فعلا نشعر ان الوقت لا يكفينا في اليوم
لاداء كل المهام خلال اليوم هل بالفعل
هناك اسباب منطقيه لذلك
اهل الخير
هو صحيح
هو الذي يستثمر في وقته همم ليه بنحس
الاحساس ده كلنا عندنا نفس ال 24 ساعه
ولكن في اسباب زي ما ذكرها موقع لايت هي
بتؤدي لاحساسنا ان احنا لا مش كلنا عندنا
نفس ال 24 ساعه مش في حاجات كثير باكون
عايز اعملها ما باعملهاش ولكن خلينا نبدا
من همم من اهم المعايير اللي هتخليني احدد
او اوصل ان انا عايز اوصل له في اليوم ده
هو انا ببدا يومي ازاي شكل يومي بيتحدد
اول حاجه انا باعملها في اليوم علشان كده
رب شارما كان بيؤكد على ان على الاستيقاظ
مبكرا مش بس انت حتى تستطيع ان انت تؤدي
مهام عديده ولكن القشره المخفيه الاماميه
من المخ
في حاله من الخمول فبالتالي التفكير في
هذه اللحظه بيكون خالي من القلق وخالي من
التوتر وده اللي بيساعدني ان انا ارتب
يومي بشكل كويس وبالتالي هيكون عندي
اولويات هاحط الاولويات قدامي وهتكون عارف
ان انا هاعمل ايه الاول هاعمل ايه بعده
وهاستطيع ان انا انجز همم عديد من المهن
تفضل وانا اقول لك الوقت من ذهب ان لم
تدركه ذهب هذا اولا ثانيا يا فاتن في
اشخاص وفي فئات ترتب اولوياتها وتنظم
وقتها من بدايه الاسبوع لحد خمس ايام يعني
بترتب كل شيء للاسبوع للايام المقبله وفي
ناس تعيش يوم بيومه لترتيب الاولويات
والجدول خلال اليوم لتنظيم الوقت اي
الفئات انجح
الاثنين على حسب انت استايل حياتك عامل
ازاي يعني مثلا بالنسبه ليكي شخصيا نادين
الاسبوع اللي مش هينفع لان انت كل يوم
عندك حاجه بتعمليها فبالتالي انا ببقى
عارفه ان الاسبوع هاعمل ايه رايحه يا فاتن
صح انا عارفه
[ضحك]
ان هم 20 دقيقه تامل 20 دقيقه رياضه
يعني هاقدر ان انا اوصل لان انا ارتب
اليوم بشكل كويس وبالتالي لو انا عملت ده
كروتين مخي هيتحسستم على ده فبالتالي
الاسبوع وعلى مدار الشهر هاقدر اكون عندي
على اولويات وعادت تحقيق الهدف وتنظيم
الوقت لكن المشكله ان احنا بنتخيل ان فكره
لما حتى لما يكون مثلا
تعدد المهام يقصد الوقت وبيضيع الوقت
مع القشره همم الخلفيه بيؤدي الى استهلاك
نسبه كبيره من الاكسجين وبيؤدي الى التعب
الجسدي والشخص ما بيزلش
شكرا جزيلا من القاهره مدربه الحياه لا
تنسى